hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 15 video
I'm gonna go ahead and call it agents of
Hulk hands just for the nice Bruce
Banner shout out they kept teasing
Fury's orders and all the flashbacks
wouldn't it be funny if like part of
Nick Fury's orders were to mention an
Avenger and every single scene possible
we also got to see Lucy Lawless again
which was awesome it's only in flashback
I was kind of hoping that they'd develop
some crazy secret plot that would bring
her back at present-day but it looks
like that's not gonna happen so here we
go let's talk about some fun stuff
careful for spoilers from the episode in
case you haven't seen it yet starting
with top five moments number five
flashback to the creation of the real
shield they didn't fully explain what's
on that ship that they were trying to
destroy it sounds like it was just
really precious information they were
supposed to implant that chip and
destroy the server then sink the ship
and if it wasn't clear from edward james
olmos his speech later in the episode
the new real shield rules by committee
instead of having a single director
really the most fun part all those
scenes were watching Lucy Lawless kick
butt every once in a while she'll tease
doing like like a Xena sequel of some
sort most of the character she plays
nowadays are less action based like when
she was on Spartacus she wasn't one of
the gladiators that would have been
badass on to number four Mockingbird and
Mac try to take down the base this was
hardcore Winter Soldier Black Widow
stuff lots of fun and it gave us the
really awesome may versus mockingbird
fight like they were fighting over the
last pizza pizza or something as much as
it sucks that the team is fighting
itself it's actually bringing Fitz and
Simmons back together they said the name
Fitzsimmons like they smashed the names
together several times I heard Edward
James Olmos I'm just gonna call him that
instead he Gonzalez Gonzalez is his name
on the show I heard him and Coulson say
the name Fitzsimmons which i think is
kind of funny like even the opposing
team thinks of those two people as one
person if you've been really bummed out
that they've kind of been on the outs I
think this is what's gonna bring him
back together this whole real shield
versus Coulson shield stuff on to number
three the reader or Gordon have you want
to think about him tell Skye about her
heritage
technically they haven't called him the
reader like officially he's not the
reader on the show from the comics but
his powers are very similar to what the
reader does it's the same thing on arrow
in the flash typically they call
characters with powers by their real
first names instead of
aliases although that'll probably change
over time he does a really good job of
breaking down the mechanics of her
powers everything in the universe has a
vibrational frequency which is actually
true sky is just able to manipulate
those vibrations her playing with the
water in the sink is just a good example
of what her powers might look like when
they're really finely tuned she'll be
able to manipulate physical objects on a
really fine level or elements at least
natural elements everybody let me know
if you're a big Last Airbender Korra fan
I feel like sky is the next best thing
to a live-action Korra the other thing
that's going on here is he's totally
trying to turn her against shield not
necessarily in a sinister way I think he
is just really mistrustful of normal
people and big organizations he would
probably say the same thing about Hydra
or any other big organization that Skye
had been working with the Inhumans in
the comics are very insular society they
mistrust normal people so it really
doesn't matter whether you're good or
evil it's just either you're an inhuman
or you're not moving it's number two
Coulson escapes with the toolbox and
meets up with hunter consider the
contract signed what's the mission boss
here's what they have to do so they have
to track down Skye Coulson has to find
and help Skye and deal with the real
shield and we are within a couple weeks
of the crossover with age of Ultron so
there's a real question is that how the
show is gonna reconcile all those things
if Coulson ends up being the one to go
after Skye finds out where these
Inhumans are lucky tracks are down I'm
interested to see how they react to him
having Kree blood inside him because
technically he's not an inhuman I'm
really interested to see who the big
villain ends up being the second half of
the season like is Whitehall gonna step
out of the shadows and be like surprised
I'm not really dead he has that crazy
healing factor so unless someone emerges
from the Inhumans camp and ends up being
the big villain someone we haven't met
yet I think he'll come back because
Edward James Olmos character they went a
long way to making him sympathetic
that's what all those flashback scenes
were for him fury gave us orders we need
to take this ship down obviously he's
reversed his position he kind of hates
Nick Fury right now but he's still
trying to do a good thing even if it's
feeding into what will become Captain
America Civil War and finally my number
one WTF moment Skye accidentally uses
her powers automatically ends up killing
someone and then leaves with Gordon as
much as it was like a really cool
spectacle really cool effects sequence a
couple really important things happen
there
you know once guys flipped out about her
powers to Bobbie probably changed her
mind remember she was like this is guy
she's not like those enhanced Hydra
people she's a good person she probably
thinks guy is super dangerous now in a
way that she didn't before
think of it as like the extreme version
of what Simmons is trying to do
I think Simmons is trying to help Skye
even though she's trying to suppress who
she really is
Bobbi is probably gonna be like a
hardliner and be like nope we need to
lock them up they're too dangerous
that's really what like the real shield
sounds like they're gonna be doing like
they want to find the Inhumans so that
they can protect everyone from them and
that just sounds like Captain America
Civil War right there even though the
reason for Captain America Civil War
will be much more complicated than that
I think the Inhumans will just be part
of it that's actually where I think the
TV show is doing a really good job
working with the film's it's like it's
painting a broader context so it's like
yeah Captain America Civil War is gonna
be Iron Man vs. Captain America they
both have competing ideologies but
there's also all this other political
stuff going on in the background so
that's where the TV show is picking up
the slack since we're a year away from
Captain America Civil War just expect
things in general to get worse and worse
with this Inhumans plot in humans versus
humans real shield versus Coulson shield
like what should we be doing things will
just slowly degrade until finally you
have like camp Captain America camp Iron
Man
very clearly Tony Stark would be like a
real shield person and Captain America
would be like a Coulson person here's my
big question for you guys though age of
Ultron coming up do you think that we'll
see Skye on age of Ultron using her
powers because it seems like it would be
a mistake to let her ride the bench if
her powers are so big and so awesome
there hasn't been any confirmation about
about a Skye cameo but think about it
this way the humans base is somewhere in
China which isn't super far from sokovia
which is the country where age of Ultron
is taking place so it is possible and I
do think we'll get some Inhumans
references in age of Ultron but the
movie isn't about Inhumans so it'll be
like a very very small part of it
there's still a couple episodes of
agents of shield before we get age of
Ultron so I think once we get a little
bit closer we'll have a better idea of
what the crossovers gonna look like
there's a really good shot that Hawkeye
could be the Avenger to come on agents
of shield and yes a lot of people are
talking about Adrianne Palicki character
Mockingbird possibly replacing Black
Widow in the movies when Skaar
Johanssen doesn't want to appear in
Marvel films anymore they're just like
slowly integrate her into the movies
because her character plays a very
similar role to what the Black Widow
plays they have very similar abilities I
will say my favorite Easter egg from the
episode was definitely like the Hulk and
where she put her fist up to that for a
minute I thought it could be Captain
America's fist that had like punched the
wall but it was just like way too big
for his later in the episode they kind
of confirmed that when they said that
banner designed the house so the Hulk
and Captain America had both stayed
there if you guys remember that showed
that Tomorrow People on the CW actually
one of those actors one of the leads
Luke I can't remember his last name off
the top of my head he is going to be a
new inhuman character so we'll see him
whenever Skye gets to that place we got
a little teaser with Skye's dad whenever
he was collecting all those enhanced
people think of it is like a crazier
version of that people with like really
awesome special powers
visual effects can be kind of expensive
so I'm not expecting it to be too
ridiculous on screen but I think they'll
have some fun with it
just look forward to sky training
montage new episode of agents of shield
next week be sure to subscribe to get it
what's gonna happen is this arrow in the
flash will both be on break so I'll have
a little bit more time so I'll try to do
some more Marvel videos next week so if
you have any requests for movie videos
or anything like that feel free to leave
them in the comments since daredevil is
coming up if you guys haven't seen any
my daredevil videos you can click here
to catch up I just did a kingpin
explainer a little while ago and you can
click here to learn what's going on with
the Deadpool movie they just confirmed
that it's gonna be rated R so I know
everyone's really excited about that
thank you so much for watching let's all
high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you